welcome back to the iced coffee hour so
we have a few things that we want to
talk to everybody about and we figured
we uh may as well just
turn on the camera and record yeah so
the biggest thing i'd say let's start
off with a bang you posted a job listing
on instagram i did
tell me about it 100 000 starting salary
dude yeah what's up with that
what is up with that jack well i've been
pushing graham for probably i don't know
how many months now to outsource more
things for years yeah to now uh start
outsourcing so we can start spending his
time on the stuff that really makes an
impact on the business and i figured
that script writing although you know
graham thinks and i agree it's one of
the most crucial parts of the business
even if graham can get someone that can
write 80
of the script and graham can just put in
that 20 of graham spice on top but it
saves graham a few hours during the day
that he can allocate towards other
things that he has a bigger roi on i
said it was worth it and finally with
enough convincing and chipping away i
got graham to post a job listing at a
100 000 starting salary yeah i'm not
optimistic how did you convince him to
spend so much
well i asked graham well i don't know
should i say that uh i asked graham
icegram how much would you pay to have
someone that writes every single video
for you for an entire year what would
you pay their annual income and and
graham said a lot of money a lot so i
said let's start it at one hundred
thousand dollars uh to make sure people
know that it's worth it serious yes that
it's a serious inquiry yeah exactly so
i'm not
i don't believe that role could be
filled but i'm really trying to go in
with an open mind and just and just see
so my argument was that the time that
you spend scripting the time that you
spend doing all these other things that
you find very important i said that
those are
big wastes of time and i said one thing
that you could be spending your time on
that would be a great way to spend your
time would be going through different
scripts that people have written for you
even if you spend three to five hours
going through you know a hundred scripts
that people have written uh if you find
five ones that are decent that's a
fantastic way to spend i think that's
the problem though that's the key word
decent
i think that there are going to be a few
that are decent
but i feel like they're not going to be
enough for graham
on a day-to-day basis i know how i don't
want to say picky but how uh particular
you are yeah and so i think it's not
it's getting graham to understand that
that's okay
i agree they're not going to be perfect
by any means and i don't think that's
even possible for them to be perfect in
gram's eyes because graham's idea of
perfection is just like one of the
scripts that he's written but if it's 80
and it saves graham a little bit of time
and then graham can train this person
just over like maybe a couple of weeks
to get this person really good then i
think that's a great way to make sure
that i see that i've been doing this now
for like over five years
three times a week i have the experience
of knowing the algorithm knowing what
works and knowing the audience and
knowing which topics do well that i
don't know if if that could easily be
taught
to somebody who who isn't as like who
doesn't spend five hours a day in front
of the computer reading ever like
personal finance like to bring someone i
i know how much work i put into this and
i don't think that
unless they've been doing it full-time
already that
i think there's such a steep learning
curve i don't know if i have the
patience for that learning curve i think
you'll find a few that are good enough
and then you'll go on and interview
these people get an idea and then try to
train up these people give them a few
ideas and hints and it will be it'll be
really really challenging for you but i
think it will be well worth it when you
find someone that can do let's say 80 of
what you do i think it'll be well worth
it i would love to see somebody else do
it first
andre jake would be a good example
because we have a similar script a
similar you know similar outlines
similar topics
i would like to see
him we just buy him out yeah andre could
write i don't know think about if andre
can write scripts that would be
sufficient for you yes to do on your own
channel aren't there plenty of other
people that can do that too you're you
exist andre exists andre's been doing it
for how long for three years not five
right not five no so there's someone out
there i'm a firm believer i the only
problem is i i i just i'm okay and i
understand that graham does need to
outsource some of that work uh but i
definitely don't want his videos to lose
that
that touch because um you know we were
we were talking about
you know
scripted versus you know scripted videos
from a team versus scripted from the
creator and um
we can tell the difference in some of
the cases and you look at the
performance between the two am i
but you know but i'm not saying you
can't get better i'm not saying you
can't go better i'm just saying it will
take time but i think that that it is
possible yeah like i could tell who
scripts their videos themselves and they
put their heart and soul into something
versus a team i i notice immediately i
just don't think that outsourcing means
that you have to sacrifice quality at
all i think outsourcing you can actually
get better scripts i think you can find
someone that can literally write better
scripts than you i'm certain they don't
have the passion it's that passion that
really maybe not but like i said what if
they get you to eighty percent of what
you need and then all of a sudden
instead of spending eight hours per
script you're spending two and a half
three hours per script that's five extra
hours that you get
three times a week i also think that
there's going to be a kind of a
disconnect between having somebody write
the scripts um and having somebody find
video topics because i feel like that's
throwing a lot to somebody who maybe has
never been in the space
um
and i feel like if you do end up hiring
somebody there's going to be a lot of
collaboration in the fact where at first
they may not bring video topics that you
find suitable but maybe they only focus
on writing and you focus on okay let's
talk about video topics together and
then you focus on that part i think to
have the like the trifecta of video
topics perfect writing and the
personality i don't think anybody's
going to emulate that exactly like you
do
um but getting somebody to
to be perfect at writing um and then
eventually helping them find topics and
then you adding that spice nobody's
going to add the spice like you do so
add taking whatever it is
you'll go ahead no i think graham
blushed when you said that i just
thought it was cute well you started
snickering first but you know you know
what i mean taking 30 minutes 40 minutes
to add your your personal touch at the
end uh you're i think you're always
going to have to do that even if you
find somebody that can get you 90 though
you're always going to make edits to the
script i'm certain i know
just like you're going in with an open
mind it's like this is the one thing
that takes up most of my time that i'm
i'm least likely to ever give up i just
think that's but i'm open to it i'll try
it i think that's how you're going to
scale i really do as long as you can
continue outside i don't know if i wanna
you don't want to oh i don't know if i
i'm very eager jack the other day he
told me yeah grab needs to scale because
if he doesn't outsource
i think he's doing it wrong yeah and i i
said well how do you define because if
you don't want a skill that's fine well
kind of if you don't want a skill that's
fine but okay you already pulled alex
well how do you measure the
um
you know how do you measure success
well if it's in grams eyes money
then yeah you probably have to outsource
to make more money if you're okay with
saying i will not hire an editor because
i'm passionate about researching and
writing and i'm okay with leaving a
little bit of money on the
table bailey
um if you're okay with this bailey
agrees if you're okay with leaving a
little bit of money on the table then
hey
you're right but then you have to admit
that you are doing it solely because you
are passionate about it and you are okay
with leaving money on the table yeah so
what is it i don't know if i want to
scale jack i really i really don't think
so it's i i've gotten to a point now on
the main channel at least that uh yes
it's time consuming but
it's manageable i i enjoy the work with
uh with you and and alex i enjoy meeting
up and reviewing the video for edits and
it's just like
most of them it's just just you know
alex and i will throw some thumbnails
your way dgb will help out on the side
it's
a small little team
um the only thing i really wanted like
that my focus is just like continuing to
grow the podcast
you know that's where i feel like the
skill because the main channel
it's kind of like that s curve you know
how you slow star in the
that sounds familiar to what uh jack was
saying about uh certain scalability uh
like a week or two ago yeah yeah yeah so
i totally get that i kind of feel like
i've hit
what i could do on the the main channel
like the only difference i think that i
could do that i might try at some point
is uh featuring more people like we did
uh you know doug demure 100 pokemane
kevin o'leary so what if you got a
person that does outreach and scheduling
it's like any problem that you may have
any roadblock and scaling there's always
a solution but i don't know but i feel
like you know you can't do too many of
those and those are just like those
those are the magic you know what i will
say jack it is a little weird when i
reach out to schedule with people and
like it's funny because i'm reaching out
on graham's behalf but then when they
connect me with like their assistant i'm
just like oh this is weird i like it for
the most part because i know that i'm
gonna get a quicker answer from their
assistant than i would probably get from
them so i think that's great i mean i
don't know yeah i had matt stoney on
like no
i'm not trying to throw my sony on the
bus he was great he just had a really
busy uh two minutes sure that was
challenging but the other people that
we've also had in that same situation
it's actually been really good so
it goes both ways i think i think i've
kind of maximized what i could do on the
main channel i don't think
scaling would necessarily lead to more
money or more growth
i i honestly was talking
in free time because i also know that if
you have more free time that can spur
creativity it can also give you time to
allocate towards things that maybe you
have a higher roi on such as like a
syndication gosh i mean i have such a
high roi in the channel and i'm working
on the syndication with uh with ryan
pineda
and uh he's doing so much work on the
back end like i wouldn't i couldn't
spend any time on that because he's like
a genius he already has like everything
laid out for that
and it's just like graham what do you
think of this deal here's why we think
it's a good deal do you agree with us
what are your thoughts um well he had
the structure laid out for for his group
right
so it's kind of like it doesn't make
sense for you to do all that work if you
already have a partner that
has the outline of
basically everything but first you want
to thank our sponsor titan jack i've
been trying to figure out where to
invest my money but with everything
going on in the market right now it's so
hard and i don't know what to do
sure alex you could try to do everything
yourself or you could use titan titan is
the first investment app that gives you
an award-winning investment team who
strategically manages her wealth
regardless of what's happening in the
world and all it takes is 100 to get
started all you have to do is deposit
your money select your portfolio and
titan's team of analysts will allocate
your money for you and with titan you
can get updates about decisions being
made with your money and you can even
ask your team questions to learn more
all within the app listen guys i know
that the market is all over the place
right now and it can seem very scary but
that's why there's no better time than
now to let the experts take over and
handle that volatility for you and right
now if you use my url which is linked
down below in the description it's
titan.com
ich you can get your first three months
of active investment management for free
again guys that's titan.com
ich for zero in management fees thank
you so much titan and back to the
podcast as long as i can keep up three
videos a week i'm i'm pretty happy with
that
and um
makes sense i mean i was also talking
about giving you free time because you
went to use yosemite and you said you
had a great time there and that type of
stuff really makes me happy when you get
to go out enjoy your time and not have
to worry so much about work it's like i
want you to go and uh and swim in fiji
you know like you said like if you knew
that you were gonna pass away in like
you know a week or so that's something
that you would do
i'm just i'm just saying like that's
that's stuff that i wish that you could
do right now because you have the means
to do so but you're kind of anchored
down we have to phrase it that way to
get you to say what you want to do
there's a time and a place for that i'm
not there yet well speaking about buying
really expensive things i heard elon
musk just secured a twitter deal i
thought you're about to talk about your
aquarium
oh my god okay we can talk about
aquarius we could talk about that a
little bit guys i bought the aquarium
that we were talking about and uh things
just start adding up i mean i bought
this aquarium all in 1500 bucks the
first day i have it my pump breaks
okay
400 bucks for a pump
that's a lot of money thank you jack
yeah thank you 400 i'm you must be
loaded over there because you you didn't
look too flinch yeah you you next like
that's it but you want to try a sewer
line
yeah
no try the main line man yeah 43 maybe
in a few years but yeah we'll get there
so all in i'm probably now in like
probably like 2700 bucks i have a
feeling that um
now that i have everything it's mean
it's mainly just maintenance at this
point yeah so
but elon musk bought twitter that's
pretty crazy too
yeah so a lot more expensive than a pump
yeah only by a little bit
yeah but uh or was it the pump i think
he
no i don't know no and then he's gonna
cancel the deal no uh okay so he bought
twitter he's taking it private what are
your guys thoughts on that i like elon
musk so i'm not probably the best person
to ask on this
i don't care
i don't use twitter that often like to
me it doesn't bother me
so i'm all for it i just like him and i
believe in whatever he does
you i have pretty much the exact same
opinion i love everything elon does you
know and i'm sure that whatever he's
going to do with twitter is going to
take it to the next level so i guess
we'll have to see
well maybe he can get us to use twitter
because i'm on the same boat as you i
don't use twitter um but like it's crazy
that when you think about like oh where
would the white house post yes they're
posting on twitter
um
so i'm curious to see if whatever they
do
they can get me on twitter they can get
you on twitter i'm not on twitter either
i hate twitter yeah see so why aren't we
using twitter because people are so
angry on twitter and nasty it's like
it's not a very supportive community i
think it's turned into a very political
place yeah like more for politics i'm
not like but that's the sad part is they
take a lot of things that aren't
political and then turn them political
so guys we have to address some of the
comments too because i've seen tons tons
of comments that say that we're just
filming our work meetings and just
posting them
what do you guys have to say about that
sounds accurate yeah that's that's right
yeah the thing is though it's like i see
myself i'm like yo if andre was having a
work meeting or if jeremy was having a
work meeting like i would want to tune
in i think that that could be really
valuable information oh if i could just
watch it from my own home you know i
think that's there could be a lot of
valuable information and stuff that
because we talk strategy how we can grow
and i think a lot of other people can
benefit from this as well so you know i
think it provides value yeah i think so
too because if we're doing this
privately we may as well make money from
it yeah and it's i mean it's also fun
because
who doesn't want to hear about our like
when we have meetings in real life we
also go on tangents yeah
yeah so oh i could say this alex got a
little bit of a raise
what yeah
oh yeah i was like
is it a cost of living raise because
that affects all of us no
no
so when i first started editing the
videos uh graham started it he he does
this thing where he likes to split
things up to like where it makes sense
in his head i'm like okay okay and so um
he told me in the beginning he's like
you know we're gonna start with this but
then once we get it down he's like you
know we'll bump it
and so i waited till like
i knew that we had it down and then i
was like you know i think you know
because i i there was a time a
conversation i had with graham uh about
a month and a half ago where i was like
i i you know i'm trying to figure out
where to spend my time and graham just
told me and we had this conversation
maybe twice before that he's like you
just gotta get like the edits down he's
like they just like because they were
taking too long at that point um to
review spend like two hours reviewing it
yeah yeah so and so um after that that
conversation after we had that maybe
once or twice i just buckled down and
like i started uh paying like closer
attention to my cutting i started
watching like youtube videos on like um
the audio and stuff and just paying more
attention to graham when he does it like
i know it's like stupid to say but i
just like
you know when you just become like laser
focused yeah so i did that and then
after i i had it down it probably took
me a few weeks to like actually get it
done and then once i sustained it for a
month i talked to graham so
dude got a bit of a pay bump and and i
also told him
i was like uh we had a conversation
two weeks ago about uh where i want to
spend my free time and so i told him i
like the free time that i have
but i also want to allocate more towards
work
because i do want to like be able to do
what i want but i also want to be able
to grow something so yeah we're just
testing a few things that that i'm going
to try to take on
and uh
can we say one of those is uh
the vlog you didn't you didn't i didn't
want to say this alex but uh
you didn't do what i suggested
what
i said you that you should bring in the
camera if you're going to be here we're
going to be reviewing you should be
filming you did not film today that is
true that is true
every two weeks alice asked me hey
graham how could i scale no i do not ask
you that every time every two weeks it
is not whatever can i do i want to
continue growing and my honest advice
was we got to first get good at the
videos and then you came to me you were
talking about free time this and that
and i told you honestly i'd keep the
work-life balance that you have yeah i
think you have enough free time with
kelsey to pursue the passions you're
making more money than you said you
wanted to make that's still not
and you have a schedule you guys you
totally miss
we don't have to go down this rabbit
hole gloss over but yeah but you're 100
but you're 100 misunderstood but anyway
go on yeah you have a schedule right now
that you could pursue passions and i
think your time is better spent
instead of trying to maximize everything
yes and
you know stressing yourself out or you
know overworking yourself to leave it be
and get really good at what you're doing
and enjoy that free time because on top
of that alex is editing millennial money
yeah and so
you know that's a once a week thing and
alex you're making making more money and
it's the family was one of those things
where this morning because you asked me
like if you wanted to what to do i'm not
going to remind you i'm like because
that's the last thing i want to do is
have to like remind you you know i just
leave it to you but you did not film
earlier today i was not going to mention
that but that was your opportunity you
could you could have done that yes i
will say today was
probably really chaotic because i'm
leaving tomorrow there's no room for
chaos i know
it doesn't matter if it's chaotic or not
you got it you just gotta do it but but
it goes to show you you've you've
prioritized chaos over money right now
haven't you that's a way to put it you
did chaos is more important to you than
making more money and so that's why i
said you could enjoy just the schedule
of
ha you know of a lot of flexibility for
the most part i mean obviously we have
the videos where it's like you know it's
more of a schedule of like okay next day
let's try to have this done
but i don't know man i i think it it's
either it's either you just
self-motivated just to do it
or just enjoy the free time and just
just chill honestly right yeah
i didn't think
to do that this morning would you say
your income affects your happiness my
income affects me uh
after a certain point no
wait does it no right now yeah uh no no
i would say alex is the happiest i've
seen him since he got the reef aquarium
really honestly i i actually do agree
with that i'm so happy with the like i
mean i'm happy my biggest thing is uh
money does not make me happy
but
learning makes me happy
and so the thing is i like a lot of
interesting things that
sometimes spending money would let me
learn things like the reef aquarium or
for example or whatever
um
not not all of it is super expensive but
learning i would say is what makes me
happy yeah that's good um but that's not
to say like i want to have like kids
and that's not to say that i'm not
completely unaware of income and how
that could potentially help me be more
comfortable and give my kid a better
life or have enough money to pay for
whatever it is i'm not i'm not
completely oblivious to that but it
doesn't make me happy directly by having
more money no
that's why i told alex i think the free
time for alex you're going to get a
better roi with free time than
maximizing your time for money not to
mention
you live so cheaply
i've seen your place it's nice actually
i mean that's yeah and you i wouldn't
say alex lives extremely yeah i spent i
spent a good amount of money yeah he
buys a lot of tools and yeah yeah like
like i mean the aquarium itself was very
expensive yeah because you're spending
like no money on rent i mean you just
bought a lego set that was how much oh
yeah yeah i bought the titanic lego well
i had that for like a month now but yeah
it's an investment though i i'm trying
to
i'm trying to flip it are you really
yeah but i'm trying to get because then
i could
if i flip two of them
i can get a free one for myself that's
awesome yeah and like i've gotten some
offers but i'm trying to extract
value out of it so
how much you're looking to get uh so if
you guys are in the las vegas area and
you're looking for a titanic lego set uh
you know i'm willing to let it go for
780 so 780 how much did you buy it for
we don't need to put that on the podcast
but if you look it up on the lego
website it's like 500 it's like uh like
620. why do people why can't people just
buy it on the lego website for 620
because it's so sold out so you can't
buy anything no
well no no it's sold out no no it's sold
out so i have to i have to flip this
before
before the inventory did you already
build it up again no i haven't opened i
know i'm trying to sell it why would i
build it i i don't know
yeah so i've gotten offered like 720
but i'm holding out you're in the lego
market holding out yeah and i have a
lego collection and last year it did
better than the s p 500. appreciation of
course it's not games i haven't sold it
but but first we gotta thank our sponsor
ftx us ftx is one of the most complete
crypto and finance apps out there it
allows users to buy and sell nfts with
no fees whatsoever ftx is one of the
largest cryptocurrency exchanges in the
world in terms of daily users and
trading volume and they have a valuation
of roughly eight billion dollars you
might have heard of ftx through their
partnerships with tom brady steph curry
coachella or the miami heat stadium most
exchanges charge two to three dollar
minimum fees on every transaction but
with ftx you can trade as much as you
want all for free and their founders sam
bakeman freed plans to give away 99 of
what he personally makes to charities
they even offer a crypto friendly debit
card allowing you to spend crypto at
millions of merchants worldwide they
also make dollar cost averaging easy
with things like recurring buys where
they can pull money directly from your
bank account on a weekly bi-weekly or
monthly basis and invest it for you
automatically so start trading crypto
and nfts with no fees today by
downloading the ftx app with the link
down below in the description again the
ftx app is down below in the description
start trading today right now thank you
so much ftx and back to the podcast
okay so i think we should get on to uh
some drama okay i'm gonna get really
deep right here okay we're gonna ask
some personal questions
i wanna ask you both when is the last
time you cried and why two days ago what
about you graham
what's today
oh gosh mine was about two days ago too
no way yeah i did like a full-on cry or
what are you talking like a tearing yeah
yeah like a tear like a you know tears
came from your eyes yeah yeah yeah two
days ago why
well
i injured my back does that count
you actually cried yes i thought you
were kidding when you said that you
cried from i told you right yeah i
thought you were joking no i wasn't
joking you guys have seen me uh where my
back so
when i put the fish tank together guys i
was uh late the cabinet is like this i
was laying there for like six hours
doing the plumbing because i'm stupid
and i don't know how to do it it was my
first time
and uh immediately after i got up i was
like oh
and then i woke up the next day and then
that was painful but uh yeah no
genuinely uh made me cry because of the
pain and were you like you guys have
seen me where it's like the pain like
i'm over the hill
but like when i was at the peak i
couldn't even like stand yeah and and
when you cried was it like audible
audible crying that's a weird question
i'm just curious that is a weird no no
it wasn't an audible i was just like
like just tears is wrong no
are did you want like them like an
emotional cry or uh maybe we can get on
to that grand yeah why'd you cry oh it
was the wedding it was just
like yeah yeah you tear up a little bit
you know but you got to keep it strong
you got to suck it up a little bit you
know not not let that show so yeah what
about you jack so when i was at i was at
a wedding the exact same day graham was
at a wedding which i think was two days
ago oh gosh come on guys try the same
thing and
and the weird thing is
i will say this my eyes glossed over and
i was waiting for a tear to fall or to
roll down my face but it did not so so
you didn't cry no
so technically honestly the last time
the last time that i cried would have
been a year and a half ago
was the last time what was that grandma
passed away
oh yeah that was the night we went over
to logan paul's house no way yeah did
you know she passed away before logan or
after before
you knew yeah wow and you still went to
logan paul's house
uh no i mean i took a break like i left
because we were all in your house and i
was like hey and i excuse myself for
like 20 minutes to call my mom and
everything oh i know you guys want to
know a terrible story what when i was 15
i worked at six flags great america in
gurnee illinois and um my i got a call
from my parents you're not supposed to
have your phone on you but i had a and i
had my phone on me took a call and my
parents told me that my grandma had
passed away and um
i told like what my supervisor i was
like 15
and um
they made me finish up my shift you guys
believe that were you crying while
working yes
my grandma passed away and i was like
15. what was the job um i was like in
the
in the games like you know where you go
to like a a six flat have you been to
six flags not in a while okay think of
like you go down the carnival boardwalk
and they have like the throw the buck
the ball in the bucket do this you know
and uh yeah that was the job so so you
were in front of people and you were
crying yes and they kept me there
pretty terrible
until i finished my shift for like five
hours five hours were you crying the
entire five hours no i probably stopped
crying after like an hour but okay
like i'm always curious like if for an
employer what would they have done if
you left
is that is that considered paid time off
or would they just say you could leave
but i don't know i mean
whatever they did yeah and uh and you
know what was terrible about that job
too when you um get in through like
security and stuff um they have like
this thing because they employ a bunch
of 15 year olds um they have this thing
where it's like all the hr people and
you give them like your ticket like they
print you out your ticket to check you
in
and then you have to walk like 20
minutes sometimes even like 25 minutes
to get to where you work
um and then when you got there they
would write down the time you got there
and that's when they start the clock
why'd you say 25 minutes the amusement
park
which is they put you at the very end
you could be yeah because you could have
to walk through four different sections
well maybe not 25 maybe like 15 minutes
but yeah but they're in back in that
time is not
accounted for exactly and they changed
that law i believe since then uh but
looking back i'm like wow i'm like yeah
that's a lot of time that and then when
you would go on your break and you got
like a 20-minute break they would like
write down the time that that the
manager's like okay you're going now and
then they'd write it down but it takes
you like you know ten five minutes to
get to the break room and then yeah five
minutes ago
i'm like dude i'm like looking back i'm
like well i was 15. she should have
created a union
no it's whatever but uh you know i would
have thought that when you get to the uh
if it's like a grocery store no problem
because the break room's like i'm one
minute nobody cares but for an amusement
park i feel like i feel like a lot of
kids were robbed
yeah did they just sneak off and go on
the rides so i don't know you know what
uh i
i don't know if i should say this oh you
can see nobody cares no no it's good uh
i used to work at the water park
and uh sometimes when there was not much
action i would check people into the
cabanas
which are just like a fancy tent
if uh i checked every everybody in for
the day and there's a next one i'd go in
and take like a 20 minute nap that's not
bad yeah okay yeah
yeah that's it nothing crazy back when i
was a buster at a restaurant um
i would uh sometimes eat bread you know
like the bread that they serve to tables
before they would you eat like eaten
bread though no yeah yeah i mean no i
wouldn't eat eaten bread but i would eat
i would eat eaten like prime rib and
stuff like that like if someone like if
it had a bite like on the spot oh and i
know that's disgusting and to someone
who doesn't work in the restaurant
industry they don't understand but if
you join the restaurant industry and
you're you know six hours into a shift
and you're starving and there's like a
huge you know and it was going to go in
the garbage and
rib that's going to go in the trash and
you see a you know a section that
doesn't have any you know cuts in it
like well you know i'm pretty hungry i
would do i did that actually at a sushi
place you used to work no no i didn't
work there just i was eating there and i
saw this guy like he was on a date
and he had barely touched his food and
like they had paid already and his it's
like sushi was like not barely eaten
and so i was telling a friend like we're
sitting like this i'm like he's not
going to finish his food like are they
just going to throw that out and my
friend jokingly said just ask and see if
you can take it
and so i'm like really and he's like
yeah just do it so i was like hey excuse
me um i see you haven't been here like
are you gonna finish that i think i
looked at it he's like
uh no i don't think so i'm like do you
mind
can i have it and he's like
sure and he gave him the suit like
that's like what you see on extreme
cheapskates it looks fine it was fine
though i mean no i'm sure it's fine but
like
i wouldn't know how to react to somebody
else did you feel shameful when you
asked that
kudos to you man no i i just like i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that i think that's great
i just feel like it'd be weird if
somebody asked me to be like oh if
someone asked me i would be happy i
would give it to him but i don't know if
i could ask people that have the same
reaction i'd have the same reaction i'd
be like well if i'm not going to eat it
like sure take it and if i'm going to
eat and be like oh you know i just
haven't had a chance like i'm going to
take it with me but
part of you wonders dude maybe he was
like so uptight on his date that he
didn't want to like eat too much and
then he felt uncomfortable saying i'm
going to take it with me he's like uh
sure
i caught him at the right moment but
anyway i don't i don't care you know
have you ever been called out for being
frugal from like
like a friend and it was weird
no
not once no they they all know me so
well that they're like that's just
graham
did you ever think that you took it too
far yeah i brought a subway to a
restaurant once
yeah you told me that you did yeah it
was a car meet and uh
i think like i would ration
like how much money it spend the day and
i'd be like well it's a car meet and we
drive to malibu and we do this drive and
come back so i've spent like 20 dollars
on gas and that's kind of like my limit
so i don't want to spend then like
another 20 on food at a restaurant and
then it puts you in a weird spot where
you like have to figure out how to split
the bill and like sometimes everyone
puts their credit card in to split it
evenly but i would always get the
appetizer which means i have to pay for
everyone else's food and drink and i
didn't i didn't want to do that that's
fair so i
went next door this is in like the
malibu country mart or whatever there's
a subway there and so i got a subway and
i went and there was like 20 of them at
a table and i got my seat and i just
asked for a plate and i brought on my
subway and i ate the subway what was
your uh what was your income at the time
100 and something else
i don't know 120.
you know what i get that i get that no i
get that respect man
but plus i would rather have the subway
if it's between spending 30 dollars on a
plate of food just because i'm with
people i want to spend time with and i
have to spend 30 or don't eat
or i spend five dollars for a subway
sandwich and i enjoy the food more and i
get to eat with everybody it's a big
table what did everyone around you think
nobody cared i mean it's just like i i
sat next to two friends and they just
sounded like it's funny they're like oh
that's a good idea
too they're like that's graham yeah
guys
i went to red rock casino today to look
at the wedding venues because i'm
having my official wedding
i was shocked how expensive it is
how much
it's like
so it depends we could do dinner or
lunch
dinner lunch it's weird to do lunch but
that's what i but that's what i'm
guessing lunch is like
lunch is going to be like 3 500. wait no
no no no how many people
uh the minimum is 50. yeah and if they
have a they have a spending minimum
it's it's so we're not going to hit the
the minimum so we're going to be at the
minimum it's probably 10 to 15 000. i
was thinking like people like 88 grand
yeah okay so if we do uh lunch
it's six thousand uh six thousand
dollars
okay lunch for 50 people 50 people
no minimum minimum
so whether you have 30 people who you
have to spend at least that much
uh six grand if you do but
i'm not opposed to it but then i'm like
thinking i'm like
gosh lunch is such a
bad time to have a wedding yeah um
but if you do dinner
fifteen thousand minimum that's what i
thought
with 50 people
or more no that's the spending minimum
15 yeah so so think about this you could
have 50 people right
and your bill may only be like let's say
12 but you need to hit 15. so then
that's where you're going to be like 300
so then that's where you're going to
have to be like oh can we add the uh
you know the the charcuterie
oh sorry yeah the charcuterie appetizer
can we add a dessert table like to hit
the 15 because you need to hit the fifth
that's why it helps to have like a
presence on social media because you
need to say like hey it's free but it's
like hey you know you're going to be
here so that doesn't even include like
having a photographer having a dj
um
like 20 grand there's also a smaller
room that i consider doing it with
kelsey i think it was about 11 10 or 11
grand
and the only difference is for dinner
and the only difference is it's a
smaller room um but you're renting a
room why don't you talk to lucky
and just get the warehouse his auto
warehouse would be cool and just like
just do something i'm not opposed to it
but
i'm not even having the wedding for
myself man
my wife wants a wedding
but she can have a wedding in the the
you know automotive life warehouse i
mean that's cool you get a dj there you
can get a dj yeah you can have a wedding
at my house for like 1500.
you're going to charge me this
i'm kidding i'm kidding
what you're getting you're buying a room
right you're right in the food and the
food but you can get it honestly
everyone is so much more happy with it
guys i agree you guys are acting like
i'm not agreeing with you so i'm saying
this was a lot more expensive than i
thought yes i would say for six grand
you could rent out a big warehouse
somewhere in the middle of nowhere it
doesn't matter
um
super sushi or chipotle
i don't think that that's what my wife
wants
and aside from that i mean
uh her mom set aside money for her to
have a wedding okay
i don't want to spend it because even if
it's not my money it just feels wasteful
i mean that is typical that the
you know the price well it's not the
full amount it's not the full amount
i've got to see that like 15 grand you
could put i would say like honey we're
going to put this towards a house fund
and this is going to buy it okay that's
what i said i said that but
her mom knows that
kelsey's insisted on having a wedding so
she said i have this money but you have
to use it on a wedding then you have to
can you just airbnb a mansion
for like five grand and then it's like
another life's better two grand on food
yes yeah seriously no not even two grand
on food how many people are invited
thirty uh yeah i was thinking like 38 no
it'll be a few thousand
right yeah like 2 000 for that
for them to bring all the food and stuff
yeah it's expensive but still dude i
would just airbnb like a mansion or
something like that you could get a
crazy place for like a couple grand you
get it for the whole night so you can
stay there alex yes get a better idea
what okay kelsey's gonna hate this i
think it's a good idea
spend 15 grand
and then charge for tickets i i had that
idea
you could invite like hey 20 subscribers
who want to come to this thing
send send an application like i'm going
to be like hey guys graham is going to
be there yeah i'm going to be there
jack's going to be there
ramsey is going gonna be there yeah but
like you know hey for 500 bucks to take
andre is going to be there just start
inviting all of our friends you could
get a ticket for fire who wouldn't want
to go to a wedding with all of us you
know what the free food that would make
a great video 500 bucks a ticket oh how
i got a fifteen thousand dollars free
and absolutely bang your video seriously
500 tickets 20 people that's 10 grand
you should just start out like inviting
alex hormozy and stuff just so you can
like market it better
like the following guests yeah that
would be hilarious everyone on the iced
coffee you know what
kelsey i don't think she'd be opposed to
that
do it right and you know would be funny
it'd be funny if i like i have a whole
website for it but there's only a
certain amount of tickets and like as
the guest like rsvp like like he goes
from like invited to like like confirmed
uh talk to kelsey i feel so bad because
you should get like uh alex and like
kevin or so whoever appears to do like a
keynote too
and you can
start marketing that
no no
you're looking kevin's gonna talk to you
about the real estate market dude
why am i not actually opposed to that
that's so bad but it could it could if
you think about it it's kind of like a
win-win like or here's the thing you
could you could do this and say hey
listen we'll spend the 15 000 on the
wedding but the ticket prices that's the
house fund and so that way it's like you
separate the two it's like we're going
to sell 20 tickets but we're going to
get 10 000 back and that's going to be
our money towards the down payment on
the house
that's not a bad idea because the other
thing is like
when people give wedding gifts they
usually give like stuff for the house
kelsey and i have lived together for the
last like four years we don't need
anything like don't send me a toaster i
don't need a toaster and like people are
like oh you should make a wedding
registry like i don't want to tell you
what to give me don't give me anything
just like do you have venmo like
i'm sorry i got venmo i just don't want
random stuff because it's wasteful it's
more stuff it's more trash it's going
into the you know the packaging it's
going in the landfill i have to throw
away my old one or just keep two things
for no reason just don't buy me it's a
better thing to buy those experiences
for you and kelsey like if someone says
like hey
here's a blank ticket to the zoo take it
to the zoo yeah take it to the aquarium
that's probably better well guys
great great point monetizing the wedding
yeah that's what i think we're diving
deep again i have another question
what's the hardest decision you guys
have ever made
quitting my job and coming here
makes sense yeah i mean obviously like
at the surface level it seems like a
no-brainer because you're like oh like i
like graham like i want to work with him
uh but once you step back and assess the
actual risks it's a huge risk i mean i
uprooted my life from wisconsin
to and i paid money to move here
and i moved me and my girlfriend at the
time now wife away from our family and
friends
uh if i was out of a job if i didn't
like my job if i wasn't happy
if i just wasn't getting along with my
not wife i mean
uh then i would be stuck in vegas and
honestly that's probably one of the
biggest
decisions that i've ever had to make
that's actually funny you say that
because for me it was the exact same
thing it was like dropping out of
college and quitting the career path
that i was you know on and worked so
hard to be on for a long time uh and
going in full time uh you know dropping
out and and working with graham full
time that was probably the hardest
decision i've ever made but i kind of
viewed it in a different angle i i
thought the risk was staying on the path
that i was on it's like i think the real
risk in there would have been to not
take this opportunity then like to you
know quit college or whatever and or
take a year off or whatever it may be
and uh and go in with this i think it's
similar because passing up on it i was
like well i'm not presented with a risk
to do something that i love to do
editing shooting video just being
creative in general and
uh
to be presented with an opportunity and
skip that
then that means that
you know will something as good come up
down the line so make sense yeah what
about you graham i don't know
i don't i don't even have
i don't know everything i've done is
just always felt like it's better than
what i'm currently doing but you
certainly had to have
been at a point where you have to make a
decision that you're like
it's gonna be when it goes down to two
videos what about hiring jack or
something
no the hardest decision i hope that
wasn't an argument no no no that wasn't
it well i'm just saying how apprehensive
he is to bring people on
but no i can't i honestly can't think of
really come on maybe it was getting your
first rental property what about when
you decided to spend all your money on
that lotus instead of
like was that a hard decision that was a
very easy decision
you just know what you want i guess
graham's very sure of himself that's
good yeah
not many people can say the same thing
yeah because a difficult decision means
i'm unsure like or a hard decision that
it made meant i was unsure about
something but i've always been pretty
sure if
you know if i'm gonna do something i'm
pretty sure about it
it's just so fascinating because i feel
like i'm you know i've i'm posed with
like a lot of
difficult decisions quite frequently you
know oh yeah but but graham is he's very
he knows exactly where he stands you
know what he is and he's confident in
everything that he does i respect it a
lot you know it's it's pretty crazy it's
like it also seems like graham's made
very few missteps in his life it's like
you know he went into real estate he was
doing well there it's like everything
that he's really put his time and effort
into he's been successful at so far
and uh i i don't know how much of it
that is like mentality versus actual
accomplishments and achievements i think
mentality yeah i think it's mentality i
think so too because i look back on my
life and i'm like well i tried drop
shipping i tried this business i tried
this business but it didn't work but
it's like you can either see those as
failures like maybe a lot of people do
or you could say like maybe i would
assume graham would and see that as a
learning experience it's like that's a
success because although i did allocate
a lot of time and effort towards it i
learned something that's worth so much
more you have to remember that not that
many people will actually try it
and
like that's something i learned early on
as well like
uh think about it like me making a video
to come here like
how many people actually sat down and
like okay i'm gonna get this video done
like
i know it makes sense to you guys
because you guys have the same mentality
but
a lot of people don't want the like the
risk whatever the risk is or when i was
starting my like my wedding business
people told me i was stupid like
i didn't think i was stupid
people were making people made so much
fun of me when i was doing like that
work with you in the beginning why yeah
because yeah people people
uh specifically like
some family
couldn't believe that i left my job at a
bank
to come work in las vegas yeah people
were giving
endless amounts of crap why because in
the beginning i was i mean
i was not making any money at all and
they saw how much time i was putting
into this whole thing
and so like so
especially like when i would tell my
parents or something like that or tell
my friends like oh i made 50 bucks this
weekend because i used to get paid fifty
dollars every time i drove out to la
it's whatev i'd leave the house at like
six in the morning to meet graham at
like 8 30 because there was traffic
every single time and i probably hated
that and and sometimes graham would
forget to send me the 50
whatever you know he paid me for every
weekend of work uh and i just wouldn't
say anything yeah i was like you know
what it's worth it not to press it you
know and sometimes i'd go out and pick
up lunch and he wouldn't pay for it like
graham usually pays for it but i'm not
gonna press it i mean there's this one
time we got a yoshinoya oh i love that
and uh
and uh you didn't pay for it because you
sent me out to go get it and i drove and
i spent all the money on gas
because i didn't i i just i wanted
honestly i i figured it was a smarter
decision for me just to keep quiet just
keep putting it putting the grunt work
in and just like doing my thing
providing value and keep going and also
one other thing i want to touch on is
because before graham ever actually paid
me for my services the only thing was a
50 to cover gas and you know maybe for
my time
on those weekends but then he gave me
his robin hood referral link
uh and i remember i was telling her that
and because this i mean it's probably
three years ago at this point um
graham would get robin hood referrals
from his link in his description yeah
and you get a free stock but graham
didn't he didn't want i don't know he
probably didn't want to pay me yet or
something like that so he put my link in
his description in the description
instead of him having his link and they
maxed it out at 500 so i knew i was
getting paid 500 bucks
and it took
this is back in like 2019
[Music]
2019 but before then i i would keep
making these videos on robin hood and
robin hood would cap out at 500
and
i don't want to get in trouble i'm sure
it's fine but anyway i would uh
every time someone would hit the 500 i'd
swap out their link with somebody else's
that makes sense otherwise they're
keeping the money i got the 500 it
capped out and then i'd like had my dad
do it it capped out i had eric at my
office do it capped out and i just like
went through the roster and be like all
right eric just let me know when it caps
out i'll just swap it be honest did you
uh
collect a part of that from people
comment
it's funny because i was from jack no
okay
yeah you didn't collect it from me but i
was actually planning on pitching it to
graham i was like if i give it to my
friend and i take a spread and you take
a spread then we can like all profit and
i was gonna do that but i also didn't
want to push that boundary but that was
in the beginning that was the first time
i like actually got paid it was 500 and
it took
took a long time you guys want to hear a
cool thing i did uh
one time we did a
uh a studio tour of this
on the iced coffee art clips
and i asked graham for his like amazon
affiliate login and he never gave it to
me
so i linked all the equipment that i
bought
with mine and i was like well if i ever
make good money i'll split it with cram
guess how much money i made zero
probably ten bucks yeah like twelve
bucks twelve fifty so i get one about
four bucks of that so uh you keep mine
you keep
i was like i was like treat yourself
well i told you i did it i don't know
did you yes i was like jack do you think
i was like because i i was kind of like
i don't want to say i was kind of new
but like i was still kind of like do you
think that's okay he's like yeah
okay
yeah
because because the clips channel at the
time i think only had like a thousand
subs or something yeah so
yeah but all right uh one final question
okay if you guys could invest in any
youtuber who would it who would you
invest in
sonnyv2
that's a great answer why
this content is incredible yeah it's
flawless i i worry that uh how long
could you keep up that schedule for and
how do you pivot
once you like kind of run out of ideas
is so good
the scripting is yes immaculate like the
editing everything storytelling
everything yeah
i watch every video yeah
oh yeah my other one would be eric you
think eric's going to the moon yeah yeah
i think he's going to hit 10 million
subscribers by the end of the year i
agree with that i'm going matthew beam
or i'll go um
uh
maybe jake tran undervalued stock i was
gonna say undervalued stock yeah
gosh
that's just so
so hard to to pick oh get colin sameer
you know what that's true that's a
severely overvalued sorry severely
undervalued stop slow burn but i think
long term when i saw there
and i was like they only have this many
subscribers i was what everyone says
shocked
but the amount of connections that they
were able to make and the content is
just top-notch
for me man it's really hard
there's this uh
channel
i don't know what it's called which is
probably not good but they explain uh
maybe you guys have seen it they explain
things about like
boats
like yeah like
certainly not buying puts on that like
immediately okay it's really good they
like they do really good stuff um or
the other one that that i thought would
be good
hold on give me a second you guys heard
of uh mr beast
[Laughter]
kevin
i don't know
i really don't know
other than the uh the boat one you guys
have to see the video you guys have to
see the videos they're really good it
just seems so niche that i feel like
could be difficult maybe not they could
start doing about planes and cars and
bikes and stuff
refrigerators they're niche but the but
the quality is and i feel like it's very
undervalued they don't have enough
subscribers i'll have to check i don't
know their channel name all right
that's good marketing definitely well
with that
thank you thank you for watching thank
you alex for tuning in thank you go
ahead and follow me on instagram at alex
so we're also going to shout out the
mentorship down below in the description
when you sign up for instagram jls sclby
uh i want more clout graham you want to
shout anything out nope thank you guys
so much for tuning in and uh restock and
the mentorship group yeah
alex underscore now underscore
photography on instagram
on instagram
jls sclby uh instagram thank you guys
thanks alex